hey it's dr. Bergin in this video we're
gonna talk about a new topic
GMO basically I have a client here who
was a farmer who actually knows a lot
about it because in his farm he actually
did soy and corn GMO so I'm glad that
you're here and I just have some
questions like you've done it so we
you've been in the area and you're
looking to transition into organic
farming and you know a lot about it so
the first question is are there a lot of
farmers in the Midwest because you're
from Illinois kind of doing GMO yeah
definitely
I would say probably admire it and I'll
be conservative but at least 75% it's
probably higher than that Wow the vast
majority and don't mind the microphone
because their other mic it's broken so
we're going to go back and forth okay
good
and then so what's the like the
motivation I know it's probably I'm not
saying laziness but it's a product is it
a little bit more work to do organic
yeah definitely more work you can cover
a larger area a higher volume of acres
doing the commercial and so there there
is more work involved is more of a
mechanical approach with the organics
Wow now GMO is genetically modified
organisms where they will take a plant
and they'll take some other they can
take a verse from something or an animal
gene and splicing together I'm not sure
exactly what they do if the corn or the
soy but I do know that when they modify
it it becomes resistant to an herbicide
so corn is now resistant and they also
modify it for another reason too I think
it almost acts as a certain pesticide
doesn't it corn yeah definitely as far
as I'm aware there's a corn borer and
root worm which the species actually has
to beat on the plant but when it does
eat the plant it kills it kills the
inside
but there's no harm to humans now I'm
just kidding
so what about if you use two genetically
modified corn you're able to use roundup
ready or that spray and that ask is a
weed killer and so the plant thrives
better right and that's what they do
they spray it yeah
but what about the soil itself like tell
me a little bit about do you put a lot
of minerals in what kind of minerals do
you put back on the soil we focus solely
on in being K so nitrogen potassium and
phosphorus but that's pretty much the
limitation there Wow
so we don't really so because I've never
farmed but they don't really put all the
minerals back in right like all the
trace minerals you have like ninety for
minnows they don't put those back in Wow
so like iodine you're just gonna I mean
like people eat that food there's gonna
be deficient iodine zinc selenium boron
manganese all these things that's
amazing so they just so that's why you
you need you know you need to enhance
like people say well you don't really
need vitamins well you're gonna have to
enhance something so the other question
I have is so they're doing all the soil
out of the viewpoint that our world is
starving right and tell us just an
inside scoop of what you're seeing what
they're really using the corn for so as
far as my research is going I found that
the vast majority of corn is used in
either ethanol production or livestock
production like in the large confinement
type operation so basically using it to
feed animals yeah yeah or ethanol is
there what's your viewpoint in ethanol
uh I don't I don't know all the ins
mounta but uh basically from what I
understand it it takes so much more
energy to produce a lot less energy as
an end product with
the the fuels and something else that's
also an issue in my mind is that we use
an annual plant so we have to plant it
every year to get these fuels when
there's a lot of other perennials that
have been proven they produce way more
ethanol per unit of a product but also
like per acre as well what's the
perennial and annual so an annual has to
be planted every year its life cycles a
year long and a perennial comes back
every year like stea grass in your yard
comes back yeah
Wow so so now what about being
subsidized tell me about what what
happens to have this corn subsidized
yeah the corn and soybeans both are they
have programs and I can't tell you the
ins and outs I've participated in them
but I was in a partnership with brothers
and I didn't actually take care of that
part but yeah there is there is
subsidies to to raise both corn and
soybeans okay and then what what about
soy is that also used to feed the
livestock is that what these are for to
my knowledge that yeah there is quite a
bit there I in my research I found that
they use it a lot in fillers in human
consumption so we don't actually see
that on the labels as far as I can tell
but uh yeah so I a lot of it is is also
animal consumption it's kids all over
the it's all it's basically an almost
every food like in in this certain
aisles in the grocery store and then you
as they don't label it of course because
they don't want you to know that is GMO
but everyone knows it's GMO right it's
cheap isn't it yeah to my understanding
that that's a big reason why they use it
for a filler is because we have so much
of it which makes me question are we
over producing because they're trying to
find places to put all this stuff it's
kind of a racket and then they had this
thing called high fructose corn syrup
which is not even sweet it's actually a
and you just drink your soda you know
amazing okay so now what about with
roundup-ready or whatever the chemicals
that you spray is how often do you do
you have to spray the ground first and
then the plant or how does it work
so with the roundup specifically you'll
spread spray the plant so it's a contact
killer
okay so ideally they'll only want to
spray one time so that you want to make
two trips and across the field and keep
your cost down but there's quite a bit
of issues in our area with resistance to
that chemical because of its overuse and
maybe not a responsible use but there's
weeds now that it won't even kill and
they've built up a resistance completely
to it because you have the soil which is
this has this micro floor this all this
bacteria that's supposed to be there I'm
sure that's probably killed so you're
gonna get all these just like in your
body if you have any box you're gonna
East infections and fungal infections I
could imagine you're gonna get that with
this corn and soy how about the seats
like you have to buy the seeds and you
can you keep using them and use your own
seeds and plant it over and over how
does it work no logic would tell you
that you can say back season and plan on
the next year but so you sign what they
call a technology agreement and so at
that point you cannot say back any of
the seed that you produce from the
original see so yeah you buy you buy
seed every year Wow interesting you have
a nice little connection with that does
GMO produce more crop than organic or
non-gmo that's a good question so
basically in my research with some red
flags popping up on in questioning what
I'm doing and the reasons and and the
effects we have ended up raising some
more non-gmo crops which to my
understanding is a lot more human
consumption
versus animals and ethanol but the Yi as
far as the yields go we have seen the
same yields if not better and compared
to non GMO so no I in our experience
there's definitely not an advantage in
yield Wow it's just interesting you yeah
well just makes you start thinking
things completely differently and the
other question that I have is that so we
have a combination of the soil the soil
this gets destroyed and then yeah the
farmer that's kind of almost like
they're stuck in a I guess a little bit
of a rut right where they they're in
this machine that they're basically
having to kind of a little bit forced to
promote that and then let me can you
tell me a little bit about that yeah no
it I think it it definitely seems like a
like a hamster wheel in a sense so you
you know you can't you can't say back
seed with which makes no sense and and
it's become widely accepted and
surprisingly enough but you know you
can't you can't save back seeds you you
sell to your local to your local
elevator and and I guess there's more of
a middleman but as far as where the
product goes like you don't sell to the
end-user so you don't really have that
control as far as selling you know you
really feel like it's yours because your
son you're signing up you're signing a
weight control I guess that cuz you
can't even you can't replant the product
you can't save back well I just see this
as stuck between a rock and a hard place
because it's like you don't have the
freedom to plant and so who you want to
you're like just the middleman
so you don't really see what's going on
so wow that's interesting well thank you
very much for that data all right cool